hello everybody I have an announcement
to make
we have a new channel yes a new channel
it is names this and you guys kind of
chose the name by submitting a billion
times on Instagram the new channel for
teen videos like directors commentaries
behind the scenes stuff like that be
sure to go subscribe to it and check it
out after this there's a video I made up
there right now for now enjoy this
episode of odd man out we shot this in
February so there is some talk about
people who have since left the
presidential race but that's fine still
a good video I guess I'll see you over
at the other channel do you think gotta
go I'll see you later bye bye most of us
have a set idea on what a Democrat looks
like and believe that they belong to a
certain demographic do you have similar
biases as well health care for all
that's socialism
sign me up let's see with this episode
of odd man out how easy it is for you to
find the super toxic
[Music]
we brought together seven Democrats I'm
a Democrat I'm a Democrat I am a
Democrat I'm a Democrat I am a Democrat
I'm a Democrat I'm a Democrat one is a
liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
Christ who is the odd man out
when did like everybody become a
Democrat when I was at school I have
been a really small town in Nebraska was
very white we had Fox News on TV Brandon
Cano is coming after me you two saying
stuff like that's a bad move for
bringing up like that I'm from Nebraska
and then I grew up with I'm a
conservative family so I thought maybe
you know him coming off that strongly
that he could have been the ball where'd
you go to school Oklahoma State
University which goes now okay I come
from a conservative family I went to
college I was like where did you go to
college USC I think I was targeting Nick
a little bit USC is known for being a
more private conservative school
[Music]
[Laughter]
first of all I'm black I think the
Democratic Party aligns with interests
of black people Republican Party really
doesn't offer anything Medicare is a big
thing for me my father passed away right
before I was born didn't have health
insurance and so when he got sick and
got cancer it just happened so late
I don't want that's happened anybody
else's parents the most important issue
for me is the environment I think Trump
pulling out of the Paris agreement was
horrible I think the US should lead this
global initiative towards renewable
energy today
Andrew yang why I think his like the
freedom to identity Palin dollars a
month helps like the far majority of
people in America I don't mean to
interrupt
but also I don't feel like Andrew aid
really emphasizes the points that you
first brought up about health care and I
think like Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders yes for Medicare for although
okay true but like I feel like other
politicians especially who's like I'm
planning book for at least for the part
what are you guys own abortion
pro-choice easy
[Music]
were you lying like was inconsistent
with what policies are really most
important to him I think a really
important question that's what valleys
really make you Democrat why don't you
start out with your own question sorry I
didn't get that yeah yeah when Sarah
started asking questions so I kind of
kind of cut her off and I don't know
that seemed kind of like a very
aggressive way to come at it woman's
rights are really important to me as
well as like environmental rights I'm a
huge Murray Sanders supporter what ways
do you support the women's rights
movement like abortion Planned
Parenthood I'm half black half Mexican
and my mom was actually brought here as
a baby from I would eat then I would he
throw from TJ and then my dad's
obviously black and I don't like people
telling me what to do so like a hundred
and fifty percent pro-choice I think
jaslyne was protected by Brandon which
is completely valid because people of
color should protect people of color but
I just felt like I didn't want to come
in and be a little bit of a bully and
try to get to the root of the question
but I would say like I'm a baby Democrat
cuz I grew up I grew up Christian
my main thing is abortion healthcare
again baby Democrat I'd like just got
into it so thank you both my parents are
immigrants when mom was born in Grenada
my dad was born in Paris France and then
I'm currently in school I'm a political
science major pre-law concentration the
minors in ethnic studies don't think a
Republican would take not first I was a
theater major you guys how many
Republicans are theater majors I would
say my biggest values is I'm a staunch
feminist like I'm absolutely pro-choice
and I believe in women's autonomy over
their body is obviously women's rights
is huge to me there needs to be autonomy
good control also extremely important
the big thing that made me a Democrat
was knowing in a high school that I was
gay and I was raised in the military in
the era of Don't Ask Don't Tell carried
a lot of shame
yeah how old are you real quick 3000
you're in there yeah I think we all were
just really open with each other
all the other women in the box had very
like concrete examples to back up why
they were a feminist and why they were
pro-choice it really sucked that I had
to like vote Sarah out but in my head
her answer was a little less supported
I'm gonna start off somewhere really
weird but it's just myself a study I
read if you guys were to see a severed
hand floating in a glass bottle how does
Scott was disgusted would you be a
severed hand intense question I would I
would probably be pretty disgusted I'm
gonna say I would probably smell what
blood really freaks me out
how disgusted I can't even get a so like
I'm not gonna say super disgusting but
obviously wouldn't my reaction isn't
gross it's more like Wow comical and
confused but yeah I would like to know
more information okay essentially a
study in 2014
said that like based on like brains of
Democrats versus Republicans Republicans
are more likely to have a good gut
reaction of something being a more
disgusting both Nick and jazz were
really disgusting and that's why I like
both of them were kind of on my list I
thought sighs question was really
interesting and what's so funny is I
answered differently than what I was
thinking in my head because I was
thinking that if I saw a jar with a hand
I would be like oh there's a jar with
that they wouldn't really bother me but
I
answer that it would because I thought
that would be the answer they were
looking for and it turns out it totally
was wrong to do that
oops for your top like two candidates
what are the issues that like you most
resonate with with their platform I'm a
big Warren person because I love the way
she's run her campaign that it seems
actly that is oh my gosh but she seems
like she's really out to meet people
personally and she spends hours waiting
to take selfies and she calls people
personally and she's only taking money
from regular citizens not big huge
donors and I appreciate that so much
I felt like Nick didn't come across as
passionate his answers just seemed a
little premeditated and I felt they were
just kind of run off without emotion
behind them I really like Warren but I
leaned a little bit more toward Sanders
because I was a sociology major and so
okay I'm a people person and in order
for everybody to succeed we all need to
build each other up not tear each other
down and so Bernie policies are you wolf
his racial justice is like a big thing
for me
immigration and then obviously universal
health care and I'm not gonna lie a lot
of the stuff I get is from like black
Twitter so I had a target on my back
that entire game
I think age might have been a factor I
think that the the four that were left
seemed to really be connecting as
younger people
what is your isn't it
oh my god I know now I was the most
suspicious of the actual mole I didn't
believe jazzing at all when she said
she's a baby Democrat that's an excuse
for being okay I'm Republican I'm coming
out this show and I'm going to pretend
to be a Democrat so let me say that I'm
a new one then that way people will go
easier on when Brandon said that his
first reasoning for being a Democrat was
because he's black the way that I was
thinking coming at it was he would never
assume that another black person would
it be a Republican let alone want to be
very friendly with him and joke around I
had my suspicions I was like I wouldn't
be surprised if she's the mole but in my
head I was like I hope it's not Joslyn
visible it comes down to identities as a
black person for better for worse I
think black people should safety of it
let's just in here oh shoot I feel bad
but like
sorry guys but not really the stereotype
of Republicans is we're not white we can
be mixed-race we can be of someone that
comes from an immigrant household like I
did I'm very Pro wall I very Pro Trump I
do believe that immigrants have the
right to vote but legal immigrants no I
am NOT pro-choice and for life I used to
think that Democrats a lot of them don't
really care about what's going on like
politically they only care about what's
on like media I really like seeing that
a lot of them had their reasoning for
being a Democrat followed with their
morals are followed with their beliefs
most stereotypes about what political
party you're in are not true we have an
idea in this country of what each party
is and you know what your interests are
if you're a Democrat or a Republican or
what you look like and it's it's
unfortunate because no matter who you
are you could I guess fall into either
category